le lac massawippi avec ses 14 kilomètres
d'eau claire et profonde est un des plus
beaux lacs en estrie
mais une menace est apparu l'an dernier
et elle inquiète assez les riverains
pour avoir embauché ces plongeurs de
l'aquarium de québec
leur mission retirés du lac les moules
zébrées qu'ils vont trouver à comparer
l'année dernière on voit plus de mots
les zébrés certains sont plus grosses
aussi celle là qu'on voit à chaque fois
qu on en enlève ses cent - qui va avoir
l'année prochaine espèces envahissantes
qui des balances l'écosystème partout
elle prolifère la moule zébrée est
arrivé au québec il y à quelques
décennies accrochée aux coques de
bateaux transatlantique plus 10 15 ans a
parlé seulement dans le fleuve qui est
de plus en plus de tests de vérification
qui se font avec le temps fait qu'on se
rend compte qu'il y en a beaucoup plus
que dans beaucoup plus de la courneuve a
pu passer
en estrie elles envahissent déjà
l'immense lac memphrémagog comme en
témoigne cette photo prise après une
plongée à la famille
mélo du mam free magog est moins riche
en calcium que celle du lac massawippi
qui pourrait devenir un paradis pour la
prolifération de l'espèce ils vont
absorber toutes les particules dalo qui
pourrait servir
d'alimentation pour d'autres espèces à
peu s'installer dans tout ce qui est
prise d'eau non vraiment puis ça fera
pas juste faire une couche part de ce la
présidence a peut être vu râler terme
est vraiment boucher les prises d'eau
n'avaient votre veillant inquiète michel
gesret ce jour-là attendait les
résultats de chaque plongée
son organisme plus massawippi à amasser
250 mille dollars pour lutter contre la
moule zébrée c'est le lac massawippi par
cette lutte là
il est à craindre très probablement la
contamination de tous les cantons de
l'est et plus encore il y a une bonne
nouvelle l'invasion en est seulement à
ses débuts dans le lac on a choisi
et si on ne laissait pas faire on peut
pas sauf quand il y aura des
conséquences un lac nous on nous dit
qu'on va avoir des quatre demoiselles
brillant parle des coq et il passe sa
vie trois ans qu'ils sont des pères dans
le fond du lac ce sont les bars sur la
grève on peut pas se baigner là parce
que ces coupables
dans la région une opération a été
lancée pour sensibiliser ceux qui vont
de lacan lac on a des stations barré de
lavage des deux côtés de notre lac ceci
étant dit c'est sûr que une personne qui
a une descente privé qui veut inviter
des amis qui veut contourner pourra
toujours le faire c'est pour ça dans le
fond que nous on met autant d'enfance
sur l'éducation la moule zébrée n'est
pas la seule espèce envahissante que ces
quelques minutes de jet à l'eau
bouillante peuvent freiner
dans les laurentides
la composition chimique de l'eau protège
les lattes de la moule mais un autre
envahisseurs gagnent du terrain sur
le lac maskinongé à mont tremblant est
dans un triste état l'été n'est pas
commencée que déjà le myriophylle à
hippies pousse partout donc ça c'est du
mérite a fait la épi jeu des chikhates
sort sas m'a flatté et vasques et des
racines et aussitôt que le poids le
permet ça redescend au fond et ça crée
une nouvelle à andrée lachapelle qui
habite le secteur depuis 30 ans a vu son
lac dépérir la baignade y est encore
permise mais löw n'en donne pas envie sa
couleur verte et joe tour de phosphore
très élevé engendrée par l'activité
humaine au fil des ans les bactéries et
les plantes comme le myriophylle aeby
s'en nourrissent et le lac est
aujourd'hui et rohff c'est-à-dire
asphyxiés on a une bouée indicatrices
ici qui mentionne myriophylle à épi
parce qu'on veut indiqué c'est qu'il ya
un îlot là qu'on va voir apparaître à la
surface de l'eau
à la fin du mot il prévoit poser de
nombreux autres bouts et dans les
prochains jours les riverains la mosson
rend à peu près 200 250 pieds de leurs
berges ne peuvent plus sortir à partir
du mois de juillet peuvent plus sortir
en chaloupe ou quoi que ce soit parce
que ils sont à corte le lac maskinongé a
perdu son attrait d'antan
malheureusement ce qui est véhiculé
comme information aux nouveaux acheteurs
souvent c'est c'est eh rené pire on sent
navas horreur quand ils vont en voir mis
des deux finales là selon québec deux
sans trois lacs de la province sont
aujourd'hui aux prises avec le
myriophylle hippie dont 46 dans les
laurentides au chevalement nos lacs sont
en bonne condition mais que d'année en
année il s'aggrave richard carignan a
étudié les lacs du québec pendant toute
sa carrière or si vous avez amené dans
un lac trop d'éléments no tô t vous avez
encouragé la croissance du mériot fait
de compter une quarantaine d'années
après l'instauration de bonnes pratiques
pour que ça revienne comme fait avant il
faut préserver les bandes littorales
améliorer les installations septiques et
limiter l'étalement urbain tout en
espérant que ce qui passe de la cale
autres nettoieront leur bateau la
créature est ouverte et puis aucun
contrôle le lac cameron nous habite
françois jacob à amherst résiste encore
aux espèces envahissantes
mais pour combien de temps ça peut se
faire un espace de 5,1 dizaine on le
sait qu'anne des gens qui trichent on
veut pas interdire l'accès au lac ce
qu'on veut c'est que les gens lavent
leur bateau en cake poker une certaines
vérifications au poste
de lavage du bateau on a beau vouloir
protéger les lacs c'est parfois
difficile d'être optimiste
il ya des causes importantes qui sont
tout à fait ignorer comme les hydravions
par exemple un hydravion peuvent
facilement
amerrir sur un lac qui admire effet les
pistes reposer sur un autre lac un homme
qui est parti ce matin ces gens-là ça
s'en va dans nos rayons des quatre
châssis ont des veaux voirie ont livré
procès dans les airs avec ses airs bleu
attachées à leur gouvernail qu'est ce
qui va arriver à ce futur la clope et
comme rien n'est simple l'eau des lacs
et de juridiction fédérale
les fonds marins sont au provincial et
les infrastructures sont municipales